je reçois maintenant le comédien claude
piéplu pour son rôle dans astérix et
obélix contre césar et surtout ses
mémoires intitulées il faut croire aux
éléphants blancs publié aux éditions du
rocher
un livre dans lequel la voix des shadoks
qui fête cette année ses 50 ans de
carrière fait défiler en 200 pages
le film de sa vie claude piéplu bonsoir
vont sur 1 alors effectivement vous ai
travaillé sur ce livre avec une fille
qui était venu vous interviewer pour
télérama qui s'appelle rouchy parce que
j'ai retrouvé le papier de télérama et
j'ai vu quand et vous êtes reconnu en 95
j'en suis sûr parce que j'ai retrouvé le
papier alors c'est pas difficile de
bosser avec vous parce que vous gardez
tout vous gardez les coupures de
journaux vous gardez tout oui je ne suis
pas du tout je n'ai pas d'appareil photo
oui je suis pas quelqu'un qui prend des
photos à tout bout de champ qu'il avec
son appareil parce que je trouve que ça
limite un petit peu le champ visuel
paradoxalement de pau d'avoir un
appareil de vouloir à tout prix prendre
une photo alors pour avoir quand même
des traces et des références grave et on
chez moi je note trois lignes où je
gagnais rsa sans est là qu il ya plein
de détails en plus vers les lettres que
vous avez envoyé aux gens les réponses
qui vous ont fait ou pas fait de jouer
un jour vous avez envoyé une lettre chez
pas sur quoi
giscard vous a répondu langue vous a
répondu le ciel qui vous a pas répondu
c'est roland dumas voilà l'umih devait
être avec christine deviers-joncour oui
oui devait recevoir beaucoup à faire et
à voir beaucoup à faire
collectionnez les pots de chambre oui et
vous collectionnez aussi les bourdaloue
dites-nous ce que c'est un bordel où on
a fait quelque chose ça bourdaloue c'est
ici tap ou de chambre en fait c'est ici
c'est un peu choqué la forme d'une dune
sociale etc
les dames qui allaient écouté
monseigneur bourdaloue grands
prédicateurs du xviie siècle fait
j'aurais tellement longtemps est là pour
ne pas perdre une goutte des paroles du
grand prédicateur quand elle avait un
besoin naturel et pressent au lieu de se
déplacer est l'axé là où elle était elle
le bordel où étaient sous les jupes et
là les choses se passaient voilà alors
votre livre c'est votre vie on peut dire
en quelle année vous êtes né quel âge
vous avez oui on peut tout dire mais en
1923 il a même année que le prince de
monaco
bah oui ça vous fait quand même 60 c
safer 76 non oui j'y vais oui j'ai pas
encore rivés sur soie faisait bien ça va
changer pas nous avons dans ce bouquin
vous raconter votre vie d'une façon
effectivement très précise alors votre
père était était cuisinier il
travaillait chez potain chez le père de
félix potache et je viens potins vos
parents je vous raconte votre vie comme
ça oui le neveu de fil je raconte votre
vie comme ça parce que sinon ça bon donc
vos parents divorcent vous ça vous
laisse effectivement une certaine
indépendance donc c'est plutôt pas mal
pour un bien finalement
et alors là vous prenez conscience de
votre vocation dans la rue en voyant les
camelots quoi c'est ça a été votre wii
en étant spectateurs de tout ce qu'il ya
dans la rue la rue était une rue très
très très vivante et la rude montée
suisse marcel wyss était l'invité la rue
des gens de maison parce qu'à l'époque
il y avait des rues comme ça par
corporation
oui parce qu il se dédie tuyaux les
métaux tels les chauffeurs de mettre
l'écologie sur très épais vous avez un
petit appartement quelque part où on
pouvait y vivre à votre première école
c'est la russe et les camelots et puis
vous lisez dans l'autre jour on avait
niels arestrup ici qui disait quand il
était petit dans son hlm à montreuil il
rêver en lisant ciné revue vous c'était
en lisant vedette kate un journal encore
plus antique que ciné revue bon mais en
même temps vous épateront franchir le
pas et vous il ya un type seul monsieur
françois qui vous fait rentrer dans une
banque créée ça c'est ça oui oui en fait
pour moi j'avais envie d'être un artiste
j'avais envie d'être un artiste et
c'était à la limite de l'abstraction un
indice est ce que ça existait vraiment
est-ce que c'était pas dans ma tête est
ce que c'était des personnages qui
n'étaient pas comme maintenant compte
tellement familier il y avait les médias
ne les présentait pas une manière facile
à la condition de l'artiste est beaucoup
moins connue que batman a alors pour moi
c'était un monde à la limite de
l'abstrait de l'inaccessible me
demandais si ça existait vraiment si
c'était pas un rêve de vouloir rêve
inaccessible impossible vous voudriez
dans cette banque pendant un moment ça
vous ça vous commencé dans la vie
professionnelle disant oui et puis
ensuite un jour quand même vous fait
mettre en congé maladie
puis vous partez de cette banque vernes
qui pourtant vous avez reçue très
gentiment et vous vous lancez dans la
carrière et vous tombez vous tombez sur
escande qui vous dit
tu devrais jouer les rôles à l'ajout vs
qui est quand même un encouragement
formidable samassa m'a absolument se
dope y côtoyer ça j'ai dit au patrimoine
parce que je fais ce que tu es un peu
comme ça mais c'est vrai oui oui bah ça
c'était mon côté un petit peu long un
petit peu et flanqué d'un peu de mou si
des restrictions de vous raconter vos
débuts et là on voit bien que c'est pas
facile quoi alors je vais dit bien sûr
ma foi il ya une anecdote que vous
racontez avec jean louis barrault un
jour vous arrivez sur une scène puis
vous devez jouer un rôle
et puis vous découvrez qu'un autre type
action la daumerie j'avais j'avais
répété depuis déjà quelques jours un
rôle dans le procès d'intention du roman
de kafka et j'avais un geste très précis
à faire que je répétais
consciencieusement depuis au moins 8 10
jours je devais m'adresser face au
public et je devais dire joseph k 1 est
à côté de moi il ya quelqu'un qui fait
joseph k je me retourne et je vois ces
thèmes il devint com et net
on se regarde et je lui fais un petit
salut polis ils étaient plus âgés que
moi je recommence joseph tahir fait
joseph cas là il ya eu un petit dialogue
entre nous et le bonjour bonjour je
répète ma réplique que monsieur bah
romain indiqué de plus horrible dit moi
il me là il m'a demandé de la dir est
hier ah bon mais moi il m'a demandé de
la dir début juin et là vous découvrez
là vous découvrez le monde du spectacle
et pas toujours
oui heureusement que j'ai une anecdote
avec vilar aussi quand il veut jouer le
père d'orphée et evilard vont tnp
avignon et c'est dans la cour ou de
jouer dans la cour du palais des papes
et villard vous dit écoutez moi j'ai jou
eurydice danu tous les soirs je peux pas
entendre ça voilà exactement c'était pas
vrai dit c'était roméo et jeannette way
et moi je lui avais passé une audition
d'anne ou oui oui vous votre ex fétiche
était le père d'en faire jouer le soir
pour villard anouilh et entendre un
jeune gars qui arrive pour lui passer
encore du lait mais alors là il n'a pas
pu supporter alors là vous êtes amené ça
sert mais déjà après la guerre vous êtes
vous êtes embarqué dans un truc qu'on ne
sait même plus enfin
les gens les jeunes ne savent pas que ça
existait c'était le théâtre outre-mer
sert qu'à l'époque avait des colonies
donc vous parties jouées l'an trucks la
france
il y avait la france d'outre-mer alors
vous partez joué dans toutes ses toutes
ses tournées comme ça c'est comme un peu
comme votre père fait donc vous en
revenez un travail de saison vous vis
exactement et donc vous partez alors là
évidemment il ya toutes ces villes qui
font rêver à des pondichéry tamatave
djibouti saigon et vous allez alors ce
qui est un peu quand même dans votre
livre un peu frustrant c'est finalement
vous avez vu à ce moment là des choses
sûrement très pittoresque c'est clair et
finalement tout ce que vous semble en
retenir c'est je me dis pour la première
fois cette phrase qui devait revenir
sans arrêt si où sont passés nos bagages
serre que votre problème numéro un
salaire net est-ce que ça a commencé
comme ça où la cage ne suivaient pas
tout jouer et c'est vrai que c'était pas
un peu obsessionnel oui on n'avait
qu'une idée c'est de retrouver le navire
au bailliage c'est tout le matériel de
nouvelles scènes
oui c'est pas tellement nos bagages
personnels vous raconter des fois qu'ils
manquent des manques des projecteurs et
manquent d'eau et laurent 75 vous
décidez de devenir un militant du
théâtre vivant parce que vous dites
finalement le théâtre classique
c'est une satisfaction pour soi même
mais c'est une satisfaction d'interprète
et en fait vous vous avez eu à coeur
depuis l'époque de juin théâtre vivant
tu vois le théâtre d'aujourd'hui c'est
ça d'être un petit peu d'entretenir ma
curiosité et mon envie de continuer en
allant toujours un petit peu vers
l'inconnu et suscité en moi
le besoin de découvrir le plus bel
exemple de ça ce sera les diablogues
avec roland dubillard alors on en a pas
beaucoup de temps mais dites nous un peu
parce que ceux du billard avait l'air
d'avoir une personnalité absolument très
fermé il était autiste ce type là non
c'était un personnage très vite réparé
je prenais l'avion avait avec vous il y
avait avec lui disait rien d'ailleurs on
ne se parlait pas vous parler vraiment
aux répétitions pour mettre au point les
scènes mais encore avec un minimum de
mots et beaucoup de précautions roland
oui c'est rien que vous ne pensez pas
ceux ci
je suis décalé un tout petit peu sur la
gauche ce serait pas mieux du point de
vue angle de briguer à peine à peine
d'ailleurs drôle de personne a marqué
quand on voit les diablogues c'est vrai
que c'est très bizarre pour lui ça peut
avoir un mental assez spécial alors les
shadoks évidemment tout le monde vous
connaît à travers les shadoks alors ça
vous a l'air de vous embêter parce que
c'est vrai que vous avez fait quand même
pas mal de trucs c'est clair et alors on
sent un petit peu dit moi si je me
trompe mais on sent vous l'avez mis à la
fin du livre parce que l'éditeur a dû
vous dire écoutez pied plus vous êtes
gentils parlez-moi des shadoks parce
qu'on se sent que ça vous emmerde
non non je n'irai pas jusqu'au là parce
qu'on peut pas quand même quand on a
participé à quelque chose qui a réussi
qui a été un succès qui reste dans les
mémoires dont on souvient absolument
très bien on peut pas on peut pas renier
ça et dire ils sont trop verts c'est
quand même agréable mais cela dit en
plus de 50 ans d'action les shadoks ont
été il vous a pas duré longtemps de 2 3
ans 3 4 ans maintenant c'est devenu en
plus les shadoks c'est devenu un
classique vous le savez bruxelles
s'était hernani cancer a commencé rouxel
ça fait un classique avec ça alors il ya
eu dans les chaussettes kindy qu'elle
ait fait une publicité en utilisant
votre voix mais j'étais pas vous c'est
quelqu'un qui vous imiter et vous avez
obtenu sa fait jurisprudence assez ça
c'est votre foi et les déposer
maintenant mais voilà si on veut si vous
le savez le problème de la propriété
vocale si je puis 10 est posée pour la
première fois ils n'étaient pas encore
posé avant ça oui alors vous parlez très
peu de cinéma parce que c'est vrai que
vous avez dû jouer des pièces tellement
j'irai excellente que c'est difficile
mais je trouve qu'une certaine façon
vous parlez du gendarme de saint tropez
c'est rigolo le gendarme de saint tropez
oui bon combat vous ont parlé plus en
parler un petit peu besoin là aussi vous
en parler un peu comme de quelque chose
dessus balle terme
moi j'ai une anecdote qui est pas dans
le bouquin mais que vous avez raconté
dans un
dans un article précédemment c'est un
gendarme de saint tropez au bout de la
deuxième prise il est le producteur
beytout qui disait toujours c'est bon
pour tous ses potes autour de 8 ça oui y
avait il y avait une voix qui arrivait
une fois cachés personne personne ne
voyait d'où ça venait
et comme b tous voulaient pas qu'on dise
trop pellicule et ses bateaux tout le
monde un jour j'ai découvert que beytout
disait sac derrière un arbre en parle
avec un copain puis quand il avait
entendu que c'est la deuxième crise
disait que c'est bon pour tout le monde
tout est complètement de savoir
ne chercher à savoir d'où ça venait même
le metteur en scène où étaient habilités
à agir au nom c'est souvent comme ça
alors ne cherchez pas la belle
américaine hibernatus qui sont des films
quand même qu'ils ont alors vous dans
votre bouquin vous parlez de merci
bernard vous parlez pas de palaces de
type formidable dans palace convié le
concierge
ah oui c'est formidable oui vous
acceptez cette attaque une seule la cud
de l'accueil un truc avant de nous
séparer je vous fait raconter c'est à
dire que vous avez sept pacifistes et
anti-nucléaires vous êtes pacifiste vous
avez jamais été au pc mais on peut dire
quand même vous avez été un compagnon de
route du parti communiste qui déshabille
oui vous ai signé l'appel dé s'en
excusera et alors ce que je comprends
pas dans votre livre c'est quand vous
quand vous parlez de l'époque de
l'outre-mer l'époque de vous faisiez ses
tournées dans les colonies françaises
vous dites là bas les gens nous
prenaient pour des stars on nous
traitait comme des rois
et vous n'allez pas un mot pour les
indigènes c'est à dire comment on
pouvait vous à la fois militer pour la
protection de murs roi comme vous l'avez
fait en 95 quand chirac a recommencé les
essais et comment pendant toute cette
période vous passez en faisait tirs
reçus comme des princes j'imagine
effectivement et à aucun moment dans
votre livre vous avez un mot de
compassion pour les pour ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque les indigènes baiona
compassion on m'a même émission entre
guillemets si je puis dire est temps là
bas c'était justement de faire passer à
ces indigènes entre guillemets enfin
qu'ils étaient les habitants locaux
le message de nos ports et il était
admis à nous représentons ledergerber
dacquois faisait quand même des
représentations pour la jeunesse
somalienne la jeunesse africaine
d'ailleurs si vous vous souvenez à un
certain moment non livres pour
démystifier un tout petit peu les
shadoks que je commence le chapitre dans
voulait pas que je vous parle un peu de
bon accueil auprès des petits sauts mal
oui c'est vrai que j'ai fait des
couilles c'est mal hier c'était mon but
lâche à mes côtés s'est répandue ce qui
est assez drôle pour vous pourriez être
un pacifiste et personnes nous le
reprochera c'est qu'on fait on vous a
souvent donné des rôles de militaires
aussi
c'est assez paradoxal oui pour finir
vous parlez beaucoup
vous dites beaucoup à votre mère vous
avez mis en garde et je pense que cette
phrase a quand même dû vous restez mon
petit gars cherche pas midi à quatorze
heures pense au mois qui tombe
oui c'est vrai que les mamans enfin dans
les milieux d'où on vient les les mamans
sont toujours du souci quand on embrasse
la carrière d'artiste et finalement est
ce que vous regrettez pas d'avoir été un
peu trop prudent parce que vous dites
aussi pourquoi noir et philippe noiret
c'est toujours le rôti et moi je suis
légumes vous dit j'avais rêvé d'une
carrière la règle harrison ou alec
guinness
vous regrettez pas finalement j'ai pris
beaucoup de risques à prendre surtout a
besoin de 75
vous regrettez pas finalement devoir
sauter plus haut plus un pas plus large
je dirais je sais pas si je dois dire
que je regrette je peux regretter en
fait qu'on ne met pas utilisé comme je
pense que j'aurais pu l'être aussi débat
oui j'entends au cinéma au théâtre g de
nîmes a pas qu'un petit peu personnel
c'est vrai mais au cinéma et on vous
prend en main où on vous prend pas mais
pas question donc un agent peut
maintenant peut-être c'est dû à ça
peut-être c'est dû à un agent qui n'a
peut-être pas bien bien organisée la
chose mais c'est vrai mais cela dit
comme je dis ça m'a ça m'a donné
l'occasion d'aller ailleurs et d'être ce
ce ctt way comédiens tout terrain ça
c'est vrai qui après tout est une chose
qui restera en tous les cas que le pied
plus c'est le la facilité que vous
donnez à des jeunes dramaturges joie des
jeunes cinéastes et vous leur faites
confiance si vous avez fait beaucoup de
premières pièces beaucoup de premiers
films et ça c'était un beau cadeau que
vous leur faites en même temps oui oui
mais ça ça fait partie où revenait fait
de mon goût de l'inconnu de l'aventuré
et du voyage de temps drôle de bonhomme
et ses décors étaient contents de vous
avoir donc je répète le titre du livre
c'est il faut croire aux éléphants
blancs parce que comme vous l'avez
compris claude piéplu croit l'utopie et
quelqu'un qui a un très grand coeur
merci beaucoup clos si les corrections
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus